[Musik]
ein wunderschöner Morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen
skyblockwelt meine Damen und Herren
das war jetzt nicht das letzte Mal dass
ich diesen Satz gesagt habe
aber das seht ihr auch schon im Titel
ich bin ganz ehrlich dieses Projekt
neigt sich langsam dem Ende entgegen und
darüber möchte ich heute so ein bisschen
quatschen ich habe mir gedacht ich setze
mich jetzt nicht einfach so vor die
Kamera Fullscreen und Quatsch darüber
sondern hier in Minecraft Skyblock weil
wir ja immer noch einiges zu tun haben
auch wenn wir die meisten challenges das
Projekt geschafft haben und ich auch
schon meinte wir werden definitiv nicht
alle challenges machen weil wir auch
wegen ein paar fails ich hatte gar nicht
mehr alle machen können plus ich auch
ehrlich gesagt die Hälfte der challenges
die wir noch offen haben nicht mal
verstehe und das meiner Ansicht nach dem
nur so challenges sind die man halt fürs
Protokoll macht weil ich blende euch mal
hier noch ein
bisschen die Challenges die noch offen
haben
und ich verstehe davon viele Sachen
nicht mal und das sind jetzt nicht so
Sachen wo ich jetzt irgendwie sage okay
weil sie nicht so als ich hier zu Beginn
drin war wir brauchen ein Bett um
schlafen gehen zu können ja ist eine
Challenge dir gibt Sinn oder zu sagen
Insel erweitern logisch wir brauchen
Platz oder eine Farm machen oder Bäume
wachsen lassen also das sind challenges
die ergeben wirklich sind aber die
Challenges die ich euch von hier
eingeblendet habe und ich kann euch
jetzt auch noch mal hier einblenden
immer les euch das mal durch ich gebe
euch einen kleinen Moment
ich
das ist ja wer bin ich Basti Gag oder
was wir bewegen uns jetzt allerdings
erstmal wieder zurück in die Hölle
meine Damen und Herren
da
wir haben ja uns ja das zweite Portal so
ein bisschen rum gebaut da hinten haben
wir noch eine Insel da möchte ich auf
jeden Fall heute noch hin und wir haben
auch dort hinten eine Insel da möchten
auch im wir starten mal mit der da
hinten weil wir dort schon so ein
bisschen von dem Weg hier damals im
Livestream gebaut haben der Wikinger
dann auch rüber nach hier vorne da oben
ist das Ende da werden wir auch auf
jeden Fall noch hingehen also denkt
jetzt nicht dass ich jetzt sage komm
hier zack Projekt vorbei letzte Folge
nein ich werde auf jeden Fall noch die
Insel im Nether entdecken und ich werde
auch auf jeden Fall noch ins Ende gehen
und versuchen in einer Drachen zu töten
denn ich kenne mich jetzt ein bisschen
besser aus in Minecraft ich habe
vorgestern die Hardcore Fans von euch
haben logischerweise mitbekommen auf
Twitch da waren ja 6000 Leute oder so am
live dabei zugeguckt wie ich mit Basti
GHG dem Minecraft Profi schlechthin also
ich kann keinen besseren Minecraft
Spieler in Deutschland wirklich deswegen
kann ich das wirklich so locker sagen
mit dem zusammen habe ich Minecraft
durchgespielt in einer Stunde das war
für mich eine krasse Zeit basti hat das
schon mal in 7 Minuten geschafft ich
habe in Minecraft Staffel 1 ein Jahr
gebraucht 100 Folgen Minecraft
durchzuspielen aber ich weiß jetzt auf
jeden Fall ein bisschen besser wie alles
funktioniert und bin glaube ich
gewappnet für den Endkampf mit dem
Enderdrachen und das werde ich auch auf
jeden Fall machen im Projekt ich mag sie
immer nie diese traurige Musik
ich weiß es passt so nett aber wir
machen jetzt mal kommen
[Musik]
bisschen hier good vibes Titel ist schon
Bad Vibes genug und ich glaube das jetzt
auch einige dieses Projekt lieben sich
wirklich denken werden oh nein bitte
kein Ende bitte kein Ende aber falls ihr
wirklich neu seid auf meinem Kanal und
meine Ansicht was Youtube angeht noch
nicht kennt ich möchte Spaß an allem
haben das ist für mich das
allerwichtigste ich könnte dieses
Projekt hier ausschlachten sowie Prison
Break ausgeschlachtet wurde so wie Shrek
ausgeschlachtet wurde und äh Haus des
Geldes und Manifest auf Netflix solche
Serien ähm darum geht's mir nicht ich
möchte einfach nur ein bisschen
schwarzpartikel
[Musik]
wir sind dran vorbei ich bauen uns jetzt
erstmal hier so ein ganz entspannten Weg
an der Insel vorbei
so dass wir hier auf jeden Fall alle
Blöcke
entspannt abbauen können zack zack
[Musik]
das sind
Knochenblöcke auf jeden Fall auch noch
zack zack zack zack zack zack jetzt hat
nein
brauchten wir die schreibt mir das mal
bitte gern unten in die Kommentare
weil ich die jetzt natürlich
logischerweise nicht mehr habe und Leute
übrigens das hier ist finde ich der
schönste Abbaus Sound in Minecraft hört
man ganz neuen
der schönste Sound
Knochenblöcke sind das Knochenblöcke
Knochenblöcke abzubauen
schönster Sound in Minecraft meiner
Ansicht nach change das hier vorne lasse
ich jetzt erstmal stehen hier mit den
ganzen äh bruchsteinstufen weil er mir
eh gesagt dass wir irgendwann dann noch
mal cheaten und alles hier schön machen
ähm weil es halt einfach
Zeitverschwendung wäre das jetzt wieder
hier den ganzen Weg abzubauen das wird
ein bisschen lang dauern glaube ich
allerdings ähm habe ich das gerade schon
angesprochen mit dem Livestream mit
Basti GHG weil mir dort etwas
aufgefallen ist und das sage ich euch
jetzt deswegen wie bereits gesagt lehnt
euch zurück
hört mir zu
schnappt euch Popcorn keine Ahnung es
wird ein Talk jetzt ein kleiner ich
versuche mich kurz zu fassen ich kann es
nicht so gut aber ich versuche es mal
und währenddessen baue ich mich nach
dahinten rüber die Sache ist dass ich
Minecraft Romantiker bin ich liebe es in
Höhlen zu gehen anstatt Strip zu meinen
anstatt mich irgendwo unter der Erde auf
Koordinaten zu verlassen dass dort die
größte Chance um Diamant zu finden suche
ich mir lieber eine Höhle im Fackeln mit
es ist gefährlicher aber es ist schöner
es ist natürlicher
ich gerade nicht nach einem Schatz in
Minecraft im Sinne von ich guck auf die
Koordinaten bei den Koordinaten neuen
Schrägstrich 9 im Schrank ist der Schatz
dann spart man Ressourcen und Zeit nein
ich will einfach buddeln ich will den
Schatz suchen als wäre ich wirklich
gerade mit einer Schatzkarte hier und
habe auch nicht bei mir im Körper
irgendwie Koordinaten oder sowas wisst
ihr wie ich meine das ist für mich
Minecraft und so liebe ich dieses Spiel
und solche challenges zu schaffen die
ich euch eingeblendet habe das
ist für mich jetzt nicht irgendwie das
Ziel des Spiels sondern der Spaß und zu
Beginn dieses Projekts der Beginn zu
Beginn von Skyblock mit Luca war es für
mich so dass ich unbedingt alles
entdecken wollte ich wollte zu den
anderen Inseln rüber ich wollte schauen
was in der Kiste ist auf dieser anderen
fichteninsel ich wollte schauen ey was
geht beim Außenposten ab was ist mit den
Gegnern ich wollte wissen ey was ist
denn der Hölle was ist im Ende und
besonders das was in der Hölle ist das
finden wir ja gerade raus und das was im
Ende ist das merkt mir dann in der
letzten Folge wenn wir den Enderdrachen
besiegen aber die Challenges die wir
gerade noch offen haben ich blende euch
hier noch mal ein ich weiß ich habe
schon getan aber nur das ist jetzt
gerade auch noch mal vor Augen gehabt
diese challenges ergeben für mich alle
keinen Sinn
das also wie wirklich wie also dass ich
im Bett baue klar dass ich meine Insel
weiter klar logisch aber sowas alles
etwas verstehe ich nicht deswegen
Challenge ist weg zack hier haben wir
wieder den Grafikfehler ich wo bin ich
denn jetzt boah ich komme Safe mit
meinen Sachen nicht darüber ich muss
gleich auf jeden Fall noch ein paar
Kumpels abbauen dieser Fehler regt mich
auch auf ich kann auch jetzt schon mal
direkt ein paar abbauen lange Rede
kurzer Sinn
das Wichtigste für mich auf youtube ist
Spaß haben Youtube der Slogan heißt ja
broadcast yourself also lad das Hoch
worauf du Bock hast und ich möchte mich
nicht zwingen lassen ich weiß ihr zwingt
mich nicht um Gottes Willen ich will
auch hier keine negativen Weise deswegen
haben wir hier auch schöne Musik im
Hintergrund sage ich mal
ich weiß dass sie das Projekt liebt aber
ich möchte jetzt nicht nur weil Leute
sagen ey wann kommt eine neue Folge
skyblocker mich gezwungen fühlen hier
was hochzuladen hier weiterzumachen
keine Ahnung was zu machen es regnet
schon wieder
ich schlafen gehen kannst doch Nacht
werden okay dann brauche ich jetzt noch
mal ein bisschen ab es tut mir leid dass
es hier eine sehr langweilige Episode
ist das jetzt hier nicht viel passiert
und dass ich noch ein quatschen bin aber
das ist ein Thema was mir im Herzen
liegt und ich weiß dass ich
schlussendlich bestimmen kann was ich
hochlade und wenn ich sage hey es kommt
jetzt nie wieder Minecraft auf meinem
Kanal was ich tatsächlich drei vier
Jahre lang gemacht habe weil ich keinen
Bock auf diese Spiel hatte jetzt ist es
so dass ich wirklich sage ich habe
wirklich so mit den challenges mäßig
keine Lust mehr auf diese Skype Projekt
das kann ich ganz durch dann so sagen
weil es für mich durchgespielt ist außer
dass wir natürlich alles weg haben die
bereits gesagt das möchte ich auch noch
machen und wenn das Ende möchte ich auch
noch ich möchte schauen
danach würde ich euch dann sieht braucht
ihr nicht ihr könnt euch selber
runterladen aber ich würde euch einen
Download Link unten in die Beschreibung
packen so dass Ihr Euch Map runterladen
könnt dann könnt ihr hier ein bisschen
rumlaufen bei mir und das wäre für mich
dann das Projekt ihr könnt mir gerne in
die Kommentare schreiben wie ihr das
seht ich weiß dass viele schreiben
werden ey Luca mach doch weiter macht
die Challenges noch oder macht die
challenges in einem Livestream bla ich
habe sehr probiert dieses Projekt auf
dem Livestream Projekt umzuschliften so
dass weil ich ja voll viele Sachen nicht
hingekriegt habe auch im Livestream
könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich dran
erinnern habe ich nicht mehr hingekriegt
das Portal da links anzuzünden aber
super dass ihr mir während des Streams
während ich in der Map war direkt sagen
konnte hey du musst es so und so machen
allerdings ist mir dann selber
aufgefallen als ich das Video auf
Youtube gesehen habe ey es hat nicht den
gleichen Weib wie wenn ich das hier
Schneide wie wenn ich hier voll oft ja
das Spiel eingehe und nicht auf den Chat
wie wenn ich in meine Musik runter packe
und das nicht dann irgendwie so ist dass
man hier auch ein Chat eingeblendet
sieht auf auf stressig und sowas alles
deswegen dachte ich mir kommen dann
mache ich auf Youtube weiter aber jetzt
wirklich wie gesagt als ich mit Basti da
gestreamt habe und er so dann seinen
Timer da am Laufen hatte so schnell wie
möglich kommen wir bauen hier wir
brauchen Holz wir bauen das von den
Villager Dörfern ab von den Häusern von
den Dorfbewohnern das ist für mich ein
No-Go
und ein Baum halb stehen lassen es ist
hässlich ich baue erstmal wenn ich Spawn
ich bau erstmal ein Haus er denkt direkt
da dran wie er ja schnellstmöglich
irgendwie ein Dorf bekommt die Villager
hochlevelt um zu traden um Pfeile zu
bekommen und blablabla das sind für mich
so Sachen da bin ich einfach ein anderer
Spieler und ich ich schätze halt
Minecraft total sehr er spielt z.B auch
komplettes Video hier wo ich mich mit
Basti Vergleiche ist gar kein Vergleich
der Typ ist krank was der alles kann im
Minecraft aber so vom Dinger warte ich
muss noch kurz zur bruchsteinstufen
machen vom Ding her sind es zwei
verschiedene rangehensweisen und mich
erinnert das sehr sehr krass an ähm ja
dieses Projekt hat einfach gerade weil
die Sachen kann ich noch mal ganz kurz
sichern fällt mir immer auf bevor ich
jetzt irgendwie sterben sollte oder so
wir haben hier 14 Seelen Sand 14 Seelen
Erde das wird auch für irgendeine
Challenge wird das gut sein aber wie
gesagt das sind für mich nur noch Sachen
die wir jetzt machen müssen die halt
dafür da sind um zu sagen hey guck mal
ich habe wirklich alle 60 challenges
durchgespielt ich weiß dass so die
übelsten Profis sagen werden oh der
Skyblock ja die Challenge verkackt und
so es ist mir egal weil für mich zählt
der Spaß an der Sache und nicht dass ich
irgendwie der beste bin und so habe ich
auch auf YouTube angefangen und das war
glaube ich auch der Grund warum ich zu
Beginn von meiner Youtube Zeit viele
abonniert haben weil ich halt eben nicht
derjenige war der Videos gemacht hat
weil er gut in etwas war sondern der
Videos gemacht hat weil er schlecht in
etwas war ich weiß noch als der meiner
ersten Wohnung in Köln war mit 18 Jahren
das mittlerweile auch schon acht Jahre
her ist ne dass ich da einfach
saß und geschrien hab weil ich immer
verkackt habe bei Anfänger Mario oder
bei giometry Dash oder bei ähm goat
Simulator oder bei agario oder bei
solchen Spielen und ähm ich bin einfach
nicht gut im zocken ich kann euch nicht
sagen was ich blende euch noch mal in
die Challenges ich habe hier gar keinen
Plan von was hat ist was ich da machen
soll ich ich verstehe es einfach nicht
deswegen wäre mein Vorschlag ich
konzentriere mich in den nächsten zwei
Folgen darauf dass ich in der nächsten
Folge den Nether hier komplett entdecke
und in der Folge danach ins Ende gehe
und mich ausrüste und den Kampf gegen
den Enderdrachen bestreiten werde ihr
könnt mir gerne unten in die Kommentare
schreiben ob ihr noch irgendwas ist was
man cool hier in Skyblock entdecken kann
weil das einzige was ich jetzt so
mitbekommen habe ist wirklich ich kann
auch zu den Inseln hier gehen da kriege
ich neue Items um schlussendlich weitere
challenges zu schaffen
wir sind da
ist das Basalt
schwarzstein
ich muss nicht dass die Insel so weit
geht das sieht ja genauso aus wie die
unsere Stadtinsel
wir haben Skyblock Buch wir haben
blaueis unten lavaimer
und noch verrottetes Fleisch was ich
schon mal ins Buch happy never Update
also fröhliches Höllen Update zur Feier
von Skyblock werden wir in der Hölle
starten kannst du herausfinden wie du
zurück zu normalen Skyblock over world
kommst ich werde dir einen kleinen Tipp
geben du musst in Richtung Norden
schauen
also wenn ich zurück in meine overwalt
will ich einfach mein Portal nehmen
oder
ist diese Insel darauf bezogen wenn man
nicht in der Überwelt startet sondern im
in der Hölle
schreibt's mir gern mal in die
Kommentare allerdings würde ich an der
Stelle damit die heutige Episode
Skyblock auch beenden meine Damen und
Herren es tut mir leid dass es jetzt so
eine sehr ernste Folge war eine sehr
deepe realtalk Folge aber ich teile mein
Leben mit euch seit elf Jahren und
dieses Projekt ist auch nur so geworden
dank euch durch eure ganzen Tipps bin
ich überhaupt erst so weit gekommen
deswegen möchte ich euch auch über diese
Sache einfach informieren und fragen was
ihr davon haltet bzw wie ihr das seht
ich wie bereits gesagt ich liebe
Minecraft für das Spiel selbst ich
spiele Minecraft nicht mehr zu sagen
guck mal ich schaffe jetzt hier alle
challenges und Skyblock und ich möchte
auch das Hochladen worauf ich Lust habe
und wieder habe ich Lust diese Challenge
zu machen noch habe ich Lust darauf mich
zu zwingen ein Projekt weiterzumachen
nur weil ihr und da bin ich total
dankbar für das so feiert und sehen
wollt wisst ihr wie ich meine
in den Jahren wo ich kein Minecraft
hochladen habe ich jeden Tag Nachrichten
bekommen wann kommt wieder Minecraft ich
habe einfach nicht gemacht weil ich
keine Lust hatte dann hatte ich wieder
los und dann ging es auch krass ab mit
Minecraft mit Lukas Staffel 1 aber nur
so für euch so ein bisschen zum
Verstehen vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das wieder relaten könnt aber
schreibt mir gerne mal eure Ansicht in
die Kommentare ich ich lese mir das noch
mal durch und dann sehen wir uns äh die
Tage wieder einer neuen Episode wo ich
euch dann sage wie es weitergeht
lasst einen Daumen hoch damit es euch
gefallen hat abonniert meinen Kanal um
weitere Videos nicht zu verpassen und
klickt auf die Glocke um eine
Benachrichtigung zu bekommen ein neues
Video online geht
es ist war gerade ein sehr schwieriges
Video hier für mir für mich aber ja ich
lasse euch jetzt in Ruhe
bitte schreibt mir die Kommentare wie
das Ganze sehen ich habe euch lieb haut
rein ciao
[Musik]